[Music]
alright Gilmore Girls listen up the
highly anticipated Netflix Survival is
officially out and we have some major
stars hollow secrets to discuss but if
you haven't watched yet or don't want to
be spoiled about the major plot points
or those last four words leave now I'm
serious because we're about to spill it
all in three two one the final four
words of Gilmore Girls revealed a truly
shocking secret Rory is pregnant to help
you get a handle on this huge news EG
caught up with star Alexis Bledel and
we're bringing you the exclusive scoop
what was your reaction when you saw
those final four words I was really
surprised it was not what I was
expecting at all yeah I couldn't have I
I couldn't have imagined that that would
be the conclusion that Amy wanted but
then once I sat with it for a little
while like I figure it of course it's
full circle
it's an ending that only Amy could
design we did kind of leave off on a
cliffhanger we could revisit and see
that would you be interested to see what
Rory's like as a mom it all depends on
the story i mean and i don't know i feel
so sort of grateful to get to do this
but I'm not even looking forward
necessarily at you know the prospect of
doing more I also feel like it's such a
special story I don't want to exploit it
or do too much you know well lastly how
do you think her parenting style would
be a lot like Lorelei's I think she'd
have her own style she might do things a
little differently but there would
definitely be a lot of Lorelei's
influence and a lot of books and a lot
of
[Music]
you